three weeks from today will be the
morning after the night of election day
and in 20 days you will decide the
direction of this great country of ours
tonight we are in York Pennsylvania
hello York how are you
wow
we will be joined by Senator Tim Scott
Senator Tom Cotton gubernatorial
candidate for the state of Pennsylvania
dougiano and former
all right and former Speaker of the
House Newt Gingrich and U.S Senate
Senate candidate Dr Mehmet Oz who is now
neck and neck against his radical
socialist opponent I have a lot to say
about this guy uh the trust fund brat in
a hoodie because that's what he is John
fetterman
[Applause]
I love it's like the Broad Street
Bullies all over again I love this
this guy is not fit to serve the great
people in this Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania for a variety of reasons
first of all John fetterman has never
had a real job in his life he's a giant
fraud every day take a look at him he
dresses up like he's an industrious
blue-collar worker but for him it is a
costume he's playing it's make-believe
every day is Halloween for John
fetterman he is a trust fund brat never
had a job most of his life he never
worked instead he lived off his very
wealthy Mommy and Daddy and they
continue to fund his lifestyle till he
was almost 50 including his first job a
part-time gig as the mayor of a small
town in Pennsylvania called Braddock now
his sister even chipped in selling
fetterman his home for one dollar
I wish I got that deal that's anyway so
Federman was an abject failure by every
measure and during his time in office
violent crime in that small town went up
dramatically the town's population went
down 21 the median income went down to
less than fifteen thousand dollars and
fetterman was best known for not showing
up at any Council meetings because he
missed most of them now he also gained
notoriety after a CCTV footage captured
him vandalizing a local
african-american-owned business he did
this in the middle of the night and even
worse in another bizarre incident
fetterman literally chased down an
innocent unarmed African-American jogger
and held a shotgun to his chest and kept
him captive after by the way mistaking
fireworks for quote a shooting he said
even he on camera admitted he probably
broke the law now naturally the
privileged mayor of Braddock was able to
escape any charges and has never
apologize to this day he's defending
these horrific actions by the way for
one second imagine if a republican did
this now fetterman's tough guy champion
of the people act and it is an act is a
great force he's not looking out for the
people of Pennsylvania he only cares
about propping up his own Twisted
thwarted ego and that's even more
obvious following fetterman's recent
stroke and by the way in all honesty we
wish him a full recovery I wouldn't wish
that on anybody but he should release
real medical records unfortunately we do
not know exactly how bad it is or why
fetterman has that giant lump on the
back of his neck because he refuses to
release his medical records Dr Oz in
fact has and uh it's now more obvious
than ever that the Democratic candidate
for the senate in Pennsylvania is not
though cognitively cognitively competent
take a look you decide we already knew
that this is going to be a tight rice
how you're feeling and how you're doing
I'm doing I'm doing fantastic and and uh
it's not about kicking balls in the
Authority or anything the Eagles are so
much better than Eagles
the chair lays before the Senate the
auditor generals debt certification
which the clerk will read in accord in
accordance with the provisions noted in
the journal will be filed in the library
being
anti-union is anti-American
what is wrong with demanding for
an easy
safe
kind of
their income again we really truly
honestly sincerely wish him a speedy
recovery but he does owe it to the
people of Pennsylvania to release his
real medical records that should be fair
game for any candidate now his first and
only sit-down interview since that
stroke wasn't any better it looks so bad
the fetterman's wife called for the NBC
reporter conducting the interview to
quote be punished she was so mad because
the NBC reporter told the truth
accurately stated the fetterman seemed
unable to make small talk or contribute
to a normal conversation now I'd
normally play that but we don't have
time right now this is really bad but
fetterman's policies and beliefs are so
much worse now mark my words he is a
devout socialist he is a hardcore Bernie
Sanders Fanboy he wants to legalize hard
drugs he wants the taxpayers to fund
safe injection sites in Pennsylvania for
heroin addicts he wants to raise taxes
on small businesses by the way he didn't
even pay his own taxes he wants No
Limits at all on abortion meaning he can
have an abortion an hour before you're
about to give birth he also vowed to
prosecute grocery store CEOs and CEOs of
energy companies uh energy is an 80
billion dollar industry in the state of
Pennsylvania at the same time he wants
to release violent criminals from prison
and this includes by the way first
degree murderers for example as
lieutenant governor fetterman voted to
release a gang member who admitted to
killing a teenager for heroin money he
also voted to release a deranged
murderer who hacked someone to death
with garden shears and another man who
referred to himself as the son of the
devil and frequently bragged about all
the people he killed now ultimately at
least 10 convicted first-degree
murderers are now back out on the street
thanks to John fetterman and we're just
getting started fetterman once promised
to empty the prison population by a full
third in the state of Pennsylvania he
seems to idealize violent offenders even
proudly displaying gang memorabilia in
his home and during fetterman's term as
lieutenant governor the murder rate in
Pennsylvania's biggest city Philadelphia
went up a whopping 40 percent the murder
rate has now reached an all-time high in
2020 and it's even higher in 2021 and
while armed robbers went up by what 30
percent General theft that has gone up a
whopping 50 percent but now in the midst
of a close election he's actually
pretending that he wants murderers and
other violent criminals Behind Bars he
also now is walking back on his promise
uh to free all of them that's right all
convicted second-degree murderers
fetterman is once again lying so mark my
words in Pennsylvania if he gets elected
the country will be less safe and secure
as a result and it's not just his desire
to empty prisons he's also a lifelong
opponent of the fossil fuel in industry
especially fracking and 80 literally 80
billion dollar industry for this state
it's what he said a few days ago
I support fracking I support the uh the
energy security that we should have in
in the United States exactly yeah
fracking no I
fracking uh
don't uh support fracking I I think it's
something that has to eventually go away
so there's betterment on tape lying
through his teeth and there's nothing
genuine that this trust fund brat in a
hoodie there's nothing genuine sincere
about the guy he claims to be a man of
the people and then what you're going to
release violent criminals into the
people's neighborhoods you're going to
pretend to be an ally of the
African-American community and then
vandalize their businesses or hold an
innocent person at gunpoint you purport
to be a big tough guy and then you whine
and complain and cry whenever anyone
says something that you don't like John
take off the costume quit playing dress
up you're not tough you're not a working
man you're a spoiled lazy self-absorbed
narcissist socialist and you're totally
unfit for office
that simple now
in sharp contrast his opponent the son
of immigrants a heart surgeon an author
a businessman who is new to politics but
not new to hard work he has pro-growth
pro-energy pro-law and Order agenda and
it's grounded on sound principles this
is a critical election and the choice
could not be any more clear hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else